i want to get a legend car you have to
be a legend to drive it oh do you we'd
be qualified alleged yeah you gotta be a
ledge yeah absolutely oh that's not like
a technical term i thought it was like a
driving term but you're saying you gotta
be like a legend yeah you're gonna be a
little yeah
dude who's legend like you gotta be the
goat literally just take a clip from you
at the surf ranch you go to buy it you
just show them that on your phone like
ass full of ledge yeah which one do you
want some dude was talking to me and i
was like yeah i surfed the ranch and he
was like that's sick dude did you meet
the goat
and i was like what he's like did you
meet the goat and i was like there's a
goat there he's like no like the goat
and i was like the surf ranch go now i
didn't mean any goats
maybe it was just gone when i was there
and he was like no like kelly slater
dude and i was like oh the goats
and you guys were both back in slotted
in that conversation yeah
so slaughtered yeah i got [ __ ] packed
i packed myself up
that's what i hope racing turns me into
what i hope i like get deeper into
racing
my brain gets scrambled from so much
driving then when i talk about the
driving like
absolutely
give me the goat no i didn't meet any
goats
how big was the goat
because maybe it was in his
what color and they just run around the
ranch like they left them is it wow is
it a wild goat
are they are there goats in lamar
california
no
that's crazy is it like the mascot of
the of the ranch is there like a farm
does he like bring the is it a petting
zoo type deal
because i didn't see any petting zoos no
full kelly slater
the goat
it's like no dude i mean kelly slater as
it says i say your eyes like
roll like dude
your eyes fully do like a like a like a
full turn in your head these come from
the bottom of your eyes
[Music]
yeah
i'm a
girl
all right let's watch carrot top's dick
one time before we end this episode oh
brian speaking of dicks we gotta watch
this dude get his dick kicked in hold on
okay let's watch that let's watch this
we're gonna have to blur this pretty
hard because it's just a full-on man
dick so we're gonna have to blur it but
man dick as opposed to a rhino dick yeah
exactly or the or a goat dick this is a
girl
this is a human dick no wait a goat dick
would also be a human dick
because that's countless
[Applause]
anyway
it's fun seeing anybody running this
morning now i'm going to go home and
take a nap you're watching dude i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm trying to
find the other one you're missing carrot
tops dick all right run it back run it
back right back
what's the point of that no dude it's a
prop
oh it's a pro
that's bro
i mean i mean yeah he posts that on
instagram too
insane not even like twitter that's
allowed
instagram is not even allowed to post
and he posted on instagram there's
trevin i guess
anyone see my man someone really had to
[Music]
i thought someone screenshotted it it
was like
is it close up yeah
there it is there it is in case you
missed it in case you missed it
you guys dick was in that video speaking
speaking of dicks man
look at this okay just here we go we can
finish that watch this
yeah
oh no restart this and unmute that you
need to hear this from the
yeah
five more
yo keep going let's see how many you can
do
no no this could be its own video how
many you can take from bed keep going
that's 10.
how long is this jigsaw [ __ ]
four more
yeah keep going
i think i'm done
as [ __ ]
semen just leaks
from the shorts all over the ground you
say i think i'm done
yeah
you said i think i'm done yeah i'm spent
what i'm done yeah i just finished
i mean i'm finished
that first one is so rough
[Laughter]
vasectomy in the 1500s
the camera dude i love he's like so just
just completely ignorant of what's
actually happening yeah yeah dude see
how many you can do do ten more ten man
this could be a video
[ __ ]
fun to do as many as it takes
i'm almost there i'm a monster no dude
come on take ten more minutes it'll it
its own video come on this could be its
own video 10 more dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
this guy literally got a kick job man he
got the [ __ ] kicked out of his balls bro
he actually finished every time
he had 30 orgasms there and semen kicked
out of his balls
bro run it run it back i just gotta hear
that first one again
keep going
dude when he goes to turbo mode wait
five more
also
i just realized that's sparky oh that's
yeah it is that's spark
those karate hands he does before he
[ __ ] lasers his nutsack
no no this could be its own video how
many
dude i got a dope idea for our
i got a great idea for the next cody and
well dude
[Laughter]
teardrop returned
you guys want to know what it feels like
to get hit as hard as i can
[Laughter]
give you a killing blow give me a
killing blow yeah your cup's on right
give you a killing blow